how to start a clothing business
so i got a great question from our
youtube viewers yaseen
love you guys who wrote in to say dear
evan i'm 16 years old i'm starting my
own clothing retail businesses my
parents don't have a ton of money in me
either i wanted to ask you what i should
do
do you think i should get a job and
introduce my first collection to
investors or not
please answer me in a video please keep
doing what you do
you seen this is a great question and
i'm i'm actually glad you're open to
getting a job i have
i have two bits of advice for you the
first one is go get a job to learn the
business
okay you're 16 years old if you start
now you're probably going to make a ton
of mistakes and the easiest way to learn
is to model success learn from somebody
who's already done it
and now you may be thinking evan come on
man you're supposed to be the
entrepreneur guy you're telling me to go
get a job now how does that make any
sense
here's why it's important okay i don't
want you to go get a boring job okay i
don't want you to go work for some huge
company
where you're just getting coffee for
people and you spend two years there you
haven't learned anything
i want you to get a job to learn i want
you to go find a company
that has 10 employees that has built up
a business that you want to aspire to be
where you can be close to the
entrepreneurial founder where you can
actually learn
and make mistakes and make contacts and
understand
how the business works because
if you just start off on your own you're
going to make so many mistakes
you don't have a lot of money you're
going to burn through whatever little
money you have
and you won't achieve greatness your
chances are so low of achieving
greatness because you're going to make
so many mistakes
on your own a great model to follow is
uh is vera wang
very wing started off she was in the
fashion business and she started at
vogue
and she rose up the ranks getting
promotion after promotion after motion
at vogue
and she learned everything about the
fashion business by being
one of the editors at vogue and she made
all the contacts
and she understood what it takes when
she left vogue to start her own business
designing wedding dresses she hit the
ground running
she didn't make as many mistakes as she
would have she
had contacts she had a little bit of
money saved up right she was able to
launch his business
and make it be successful so that's
number one again you want to go find an
entrepreneur who you respect you look up
to you can learn a lot from
and work hard like be an ideal employee
don't just do what you're hired to do
you want to learn the business
right so get as close to the
entrepreneur founder as you can take on
as many projects as you can
imagine it was your own business because
soon it's going to be your own business
and you want to be able to make mistakes
while getting paid
this is like being paid to go to
university
to learn the ropes so find that company
okay the second thing is get started
okay but start
small a lot of entrepreneurs especially
in the fashion business
they see the orders right if you want to
make a deal with somebody to supply this
stuff to you whatever shirts hoodies
whatever you're making
the cost per unit is so high in small
quantities right you want to order 10
t-shirts it's going to cost you a lot of
money
you're going to lose money on those 10
shirts where
these suppliers they want you buying a
thousand five thousand
ten thousand shirts that's when the cost
per unit goes down
and you see those price breaks you think
wow okay you know what to make this
worthwhile
i gotta order five thousand shirts and
you go out
you make the order you make mistakes
because it's your first time doing it
maybe you've used the wrong you know
shirt quality
the colors don't come out great it's the
wrong pattern whatever it is you're
going to make a lot of mistakes
you spend all your money buying these 5
000 shirts
and you're stuck with 4997 of them
in your closet in your garage
wherever because you've sold three and
the rest you can't get rid of
that happens so often and you're just
stuck with all this inventory that
you've poured
all your money into the better way to go
is to start with a print on demand
service
look at zazza look at cafe press
whatever it is a t-shirt print on demand
service where you're not spending any
money
now you may be saying okay evan well
that's great but those guys make all the
profits i barely make any i may only
make a dollar a shirt
and i'm selling to those guys it doesn't
matter
because the first part of your business
here isn't to make
tons of money it's to prove your concept
what i want you to do is is go to one of
those sites
and sell 100 t-shirts sell 500 t-shirts
then you know hey this design really
takes off you may have one out of 100
designs
that really take off and then you know
okay you know what
i can afford now to go and make this one
design that's
doing awesome for us and do my own print
run
and keep all the profits for it your
chances of success
go up dramatically because you've tested
your designs
without having to spend any money on it
so one go get a job learn from somebody
in the business
who has done it who's built the ideal
company from you and get as close
to that founder as possible to learn
from them
and two start small don't go out
spending any money
put your designs on a print for demand
service
test it make sure you get some results
make sure you get some people buying
your stuff and are excited by it
before you create your first order
believe for those who watch you like the
video please click on the link that
that supports me in making these videos
below leave a comment let me know what
you think and click on my face subscribe
to the channel
thank you so much i'll see you soon